come quando
siamo usciti da lì ma per farlo non
c'era niente di strano la stima che il
prodotto promo scappare dal bambino
cattivo cerchi più bambino e tipo un
neonato quindi dovremmo scappare da un
cattivo sembra così facile ingerire sky
bruno quelle che sembrano più facili se
non puoi le più difficili ma veniamo
dove questo bambino cattivo ecco non lo
vedete la
maschera laggiù o meni assicura e densi
laggiù ha giocato questo bambino infatti
dal bambino gigante cattivo dobbiamo
scappare ok e voi che lo visiti ancora
mette ben ben 20 toni mettetevi comodi
fini tifo corum bisogna mangiare
qualcosa da bere la
cornell educative nominato
maltrattamenti qua allora inizia il
nostro partner per ora sembra farci artù
anzi quante volte si procederà vitale io
guardo che non faccia naturalista
com'era anita di ritorno non chiamo di
più vitale per ora
numerato e si è trasformato
nuovo come farò io non mi do brasil ata
e col bambino cattivo beh dobbiamo
scappare dal bambino ma stiamo andando
in quella direzione
qualcosa mi dice che forse si mangerà
pure eccola giu vita che coltiva il suo
parco
superstar t ok possiamo mandare qualcosa
mi dice che siamo vicini a poco a poco
cosa farà questo bambino cioè perché
cattivo questo bambino oltre ad avere
gli occhi verdi forse perché sembra e
scienze e mangiato tutto il cibo e
quindi bella certo senso sono false le
persone già capito ma come questo
allora io sono già passato avantissimo
dai la vita sbrigati liberato ma guarda
te ho notato qualcosa di certo cosa in
battle guardate laggiù c'è una foto con
un gatto
tipo facendo una società
bellissima bar a fianco alla pianta
l'hai visto
carino ma tu allora adesso stiamo
saltando su questi che sembrano dei
lecca lecca ma che no non credo realtà
forse sono dei pesi ma che ci fa un
bambino coi pesi credo che sono quei
giochi vincolate quella rimaneva che
c'erano prima quelli quei giochi
magnetici no tipo le maracas dentro
c'erano dei ma che cosa dicendo guarda
fanno rumore ma tu intendi il geom anche
si prova
a
ragionare sulla luce sul fatto allora
adesso siamo alla scacchiera della
scacchiera non è difficile
sono in testa adesso però andiamo ad
affrontare il bambino neonato non riesco
a passare poi c'è il labirinto così so
che è vitale si perderà perché il punto
debole di evitare solo in abete in noi
non riesce a passare lì la bdt gen si
perde sempre e rimane catturato e poi
bisogna aspettarlo per mezz'ora
ed eccomi sono anch'io alle nuvole
poi non posso parlare al lato quasi un
muro invisibile che mi blocca quindi
bisogna per forza passare qui forse sono
dei pannolini questi non solo
di vento e lava riguarda che sono quindi
come
ho detto io sono migliorato un sacco
dove siamo adesso la navicella spaziale
no
che cos'è come chitarra ma lei era
ancora i giochi dei bambini ma siamo
ritornati al punto di partenza
possibile
era una trappola dobbiamo fare le scelte
qui è bene ma io un giallo
che proviamo celeste
ed hai provato adesso vediamo quel
trucchetto che ci avete già
allora dovrebbe essere di nuovo giallo
e si bisogna per la strage lato ioso il
verde il trucchetto e passare così e
vedere in quale riesce a passare un
quindicenne
prego perché salgo in modo così strano e
museale però adesso non sono saltare su
delle mensole c'è il liquido verde che
sembra dello slide tifo no penso che sia
rimborso di quel bambino ma l'uomo
guarda ci
troviamo ci siamo ci dobbiamo lanciare
sul pupazzo vada male al bambino ma
l'etica non vedo l'ora di applicarle e
avete visto le scorte è che i rom dove
vive si sfracella ancora di più di
quattro sì stessi io vado verso
aver visto la roma in cui sappiamo dalle
banane mangia per fare l'editore quello
scritto volete vederla assolutamente
perché fa troppo ridere poi si
trasformiamo anche noi banane ci siamo
divertiti come troy dopo questo video
andate a vedere anche il laboratorio di
doctor grimm perché fa un sacco ridere
anche quello scusa se sono stato appena
mangiato dal bambino però io sono già
nella bocca del bambino vediamo che cosa
ve li ha dentro c'è qualcosa che non va
sicuramente perché certi pò dell'eden
delle ossa che scendono tutti intorno ad
una spina dorsale ma come detto cosa è
successo e portiamo giù perché allora
che come i genitori di davano da
mangiare qualcosa di strano nel biberon
come abbiamo visto lui ha mangiato i
genitori sono le ossa di cimino
è possibile che fatto bambino
al contrario o no unità mista superato
già
non mi prenderei mai
parlare davanti ha superato che ora
hanno capito
che ci credo mi ha detto mi sono
sfracellata possibile ok prima le cose
sono poi dietro mi mancano tuttavia
molise si sfracella
perché dovrei
kozuch
azionisti sera magia capitale da piccolo
era anche una fetta di pizza
[Musica]
per momento sono finita di buffoni dal
ftd from allora questa probabilmente la
parte più difficile la pizza c'è una
busta di patatine veneto poi c'è questo
non so che cos'è di rito ma i
giovani tosco la buccia ecco la busta
è stata
una crostata qui c'è anche uno dog poi
un qualcosa una bottiglia intera e poi
comprerò non credo sia diventato cattivo
il gigantesco detto bambino con cristo
andato a finire gioco ciao
prende prima in legge ma dove siamo
finiti siamo in un mondo parallelo
che siamo usciti da lì ma poca roba
non c'era niente di strano
però se passiamo alla prossima e skype
room eccoci qua nuovissima e proteste
ski promo non l'abbiamo mai probabile
trasformeranno in cui scappare dal bo
nei commenti avete mai giocato a bowling
e se avete mai giocato quasi strike che
avete fatto
avete mai fatto uno strike vuol dire
quando lanciate la palla da bowling è
riuscita a far cadere tutti i birilli lo
strike è molto difficile però a volte ci
si può riuscire dobbiamo scappare usa la
palla da bowling per andare nella
prossima area
qualcosa come quanto la roma
ma è così wow presto però dobbiamo
scappare marelli questa è la fabbrica
dei birilli stai attento l'ala ma perché
i birilli si fanno con la lava con la
sua amica se sempre
attenta perché questo gira cosa
non mi cacciarono sbagliato la squadra
credo dobbiamo credere ma
chi è che era un rumore di un qualcosa
che taglia che affermi una fetta della
grandezza affitterà
tronchi e dei tronchi che puoi fare è
però nei geni dei tronchi forse sì ma
perché ha sposato
con il
[Musica]
percorso è stato bravo anton gaia verrà
trasformato in birillo
piattaforme sembrano un po
forti
e meglio che salti velocemente si voglia
di caro
avete lasciato un baby ace
sembrava c'è ancora lasciato un mi piace
lo so se bubi show
perché non avete lasciato mi dovete
cliccare mi piace adesso corri corri
quale abbiamo come 6 dello
stesso massima c'è la fin qui perché
esso per difficile perché quelli passati
ti fa sentire certi mano
sappiamo sappiamo che cosa dice che
passano il pane lavori indicati questa
nella stanza del delle palle da bowling
stai attento quando salti che gli stiamo
attenti via a ecco perché è brutto non
mi e saltare libero bastano le pare
vogliamo il replay in questo momento
portare il libro
e ora quindi consiglia ma in questo caso
nera anche a me probabilmente veniva poi
capito come si fa a passare si sente
cantare velocissimamente devi puoi
passare prima di rivelare mai o no droga
anch'io piace questo libro un mezzo per
divertente vari tool avanti perché io
non sono riuscito a capire come si fa a
passare da qui poi alla fine di queste
scrivete nei commenti se vi è piaciuta
di più la prima equipe room quindi del
bambino magnetico o la seconda del
bowling
al momento a me piace di più questa lo
sai perché ma vediamo fino alla fine
come sarà ecco vitale ce la farà se lo
farà vitale allora non ti nascondo che
questa parte forse la più difficile
questa con il doppio salto si è
abbastanza difficile attento abbastanza
sente
fino a qui dobbiamo dare
stock ha detto aiuto tani soffra
attento attento dopo le partner o grappa
spiaccicata dai celebri marcia da esse
ce l'ha fatta vitale siamo a posto
parecchi però fatto per un soffio è
bravo non ci credo sono avantissimo ma
adesso dove dobbiamo andare dobbiamo
scendere gioco versailles per l wow che
salto gigantesco ma qui c'è una forte
andiamo di qua
attenta qui c'è qualcosa che non quadra
c'è scritto questa è la parte
abbandonata della sala da bowling stai
attento a quel gigante cioè quel muro a
muro gica anche dai burro sta venendo
verso di noi dobbiamo abbassare di
affinare quindi tipo se ti piace
dobbiamo nascondere ho capito ho capito
dice
no
non c'è nemmeno in atto c'è mancato poco
sta andando verso la porta bene speriamo
di parte lo speriamo di farcela prima
che potevano
no vabbè non ci credo ce l'avevo fatta
ma il burro mia spiaccicato ha detto
siete a questa fai la mossa solo dopo la
parte colta e più di no allora bisogna
ok vi vogliamo aiuti di andare così le
cose questa roba a sinistra tutta lines
con de qua prezzo prezzo prezzo più
attoniti
devi correre i velocisti
ma perché ha preso anche me io ero già
dentro
ma non è tutto come si fa portare questa
parte riproviamo ma forse questo gioco è
pagato e non si può arrivare in tempo
proviamoci
sei riuscita no
ce l'hai fatta l'accaduto
quindi c'è il modo di farcela reggiano
botta in cui fortunati to die eccomi
l'obiettivo per vittorio
bugli ha portato loro ha portato il
bureau li ha
passati allora bisogna aspettiamo che
passi il prossimo poi vediamo
c'è una porta che a destra ma non so se
dobbiamo andare lì e valutati hanno
tanti che ho paura che ti prende ok
abbia via via via via via viani ha
rovinato tutto
ridotto del dritto periodo hanno chiesto
caso di traverso eva peron paita poletti
che non credo che rossi genoa c'è la via
giusta tempo abbiamo pasta dove siamo
ciao
forse ci si arrampica si è arrampicata
acqui asti gli funziona
questa è sicuramente la strada andiamo
con il calcio
qui è dove si dice l'esperto
che bello se una modesta che dice questo
siamo nel clou machine ma aspetta ma
questi sembrano tutti i circuiti
elettrici perché ci sono delle fontane
d'acqua sia stato utilizzato era visto
come si sfracelli ti dà la scossa brava
ok sappiamo c'è la supervelocità
civica
[Musica]
e sono caduto no no sono qua sotto store
negando purtroppo tipo che cosa cela
sotto lo sono diventato blu
guardia che ti sta interessato anche tu
passi dai io sono fatta quindi vuol dire
che ce la puoi fare anche tu non lo so
mi sto rimpicciolendo sempre di più non
so che stai a vedere che cosa sta
succedendo se si è bagnato e gesso ecco
allora allenato prendiamo questo è
uguale
aspetta un momento perché questo è stato
il cancello o altre le cose che farei ma
le palline va quindi dove dobbiamo
andare dobbiamo buttarci giù con inganno
forza buttarvi giù ha funzionato forse
bisogna cadere qui nella parte dove si
scelse nella parte dove si scende dal
gioco sì perché poi magari ci porta i
pupazzi lì li puoi prendere da ieri da
guerra qui
[Musica]
doveva salire subire di fiducia ok a
tetti alberi lo sbaglio i birilli
mantiene l'equilibrio si è quindi mezzo
il miglior band a chi ha detto che la
riduzione o meglio ancora arrivati al
budget che ha capito che la fa capire
del giorno era solo per metterti fretta
meglio così perché adoro che se che il
rum vorrei un sacco di altri stage
adesso stiamo risalendo sopra la prova
sheen
adoro quando noi siamo piccolini e ci
sono le cose invece niente anzi troppo
belli dottissime gigante rime
siamo nell'attico del bowling
se c'è qualcosa per spegnere quel fuoco
cosa e ai popoli ma ora brucerà tutto
dobbiamo trevor estintore che ci pensa
che tutto questo pulsante non so se
questo pulsante intenso di quello ok lo
premuto e ora
aspetto il fuoco mentre il fuoco non ti
strage la re ci provi
perché si rilassa sul fuoco e aspetta un
idea spegne il fuoco così io posso
abbassare non mi piace scrivere perché
pure io rimango lì
da qualcuno però
26 qualche altro personale vaio aspetto
fuori sta spegnendo il fuoco a spegnere
grazie cerci non è giusto giusto
arrivato anche troppo
povero vitale però fra taranto 3 con un
terzo se io torno indietro e spegne il
colore fuga spendere poi rimangono entra
poi in città beh ci riprovo comunque
vitale sei riuscito riuscito a
strappare
l'aiuto di nettuno corsa dove i propri
doveri
[Applauso]
abbiamo fatto è che probabilità già vi
piace iscriverti ai commenti qual è
stata la vostra preferita la prima la
seconda e ora vi lasciamo quale servire
su cui applicare per vedere i nostri
altri video il caso quella dovrà ferite
e buona visione shop